[Musique]
bonsoir des enfants ont joué ce soir
nous venons vous dire au revoir car nous
partons pour notre nouveau voyage où
grosso c'est bien triste de vous quitter
moi aussi au saut où il pas trop mais
vous le savez nous reviendrons le plus
vite possible vous retrouver et nous
aurons des tas de belle histoire à vous
raconter alors je veux un patron oui
descend vite nounours et en bracelet
bien fort de ma part oui
[Musique]
la jemaye encore des mouchoirs et ma
poupée préférée
bonsoir les petits voyageurs comment
vous faites encore vos bagages
cette fois c'est fini on a tout préparé
pour notre départ demain matin et vous
ne nous vous n'avez rien oublié
d'emporter dans magma
oui oui oui tout juste si on viendra
bientôt tienne nous france à supporter
on voyage un très gros pot de miel mais
ne mangent pas tous premiers jours où
des enfants j'en mangerais une seule
cuillère chaque jour est un fait
passerelle oui c'est promis merci le
cher petit ami
7 vous viendrez dans un mois chicago
vous n'oublierez pas d'emmener le petit
poussin avec vous oh non on mettra avec
une maman poule i n'aura bien chaud il
s'amusera avec d'autres petits puissent
talbot et aux patrons jarry allons les
enfants au dodo ulysse m'appelle menly
ou bien grosse fessée on a pris une
belle chanson pour toi et pour ellis
parce que nous vous aimons beaucoup
beaucoup
oui beaucoup comme ça moi c'est la fin
de la journée c'est le moment
cochet
amis ils s'en vont tous au lit nous y
allons aussi comme à 10
je n'en sais rien au gel autant dire
ni nous dira fermez vos yeux et dormi
tous les deux nous sommes bien dans
notre lit au sauf vous souhaite bonne
amie savons ce mois
plaisir au pouvoir mais de petits amis
au revoir votre chanson est très belle
vous voyez bien ton nom
à bientôt les enfants
[Musique]
au revoir petit louis au revoir petite
mirabelle passer de belles vacances et
soyez bien gentil n'oubliez pas d'aller
vous coucher sagement chaque soir et
nous reviendrons bientôt vous voir
allons allons ne sois pas triste
nounours car les petits enfants savent
bien qu'on reviendra vite ils ne sont
pas tristes d'encore pas trop peu je les
aime beaucoup wa subtil tout est en
ordre pour le voyage voulu patron tout
alors en route pour voir tous nos amis
et à bientôt
bonne nuit
[Musique]